for a studio to give you a movie like
Guardians of the Galaxy
to say here
is
it just doesn't it seems unheard of I
would say I pushed really hard but also
I didn't push hard at all so it was a
combination you know because I was ready
to quit directing you know really 100 I
was like listen I was seeing how the
tide was turning I was seeing that you
know they were stopping making you know
mid-budget films
um and that I always liked creating
things that were somewhat within the
zeitgeist
and I was seeing that most of the movies
that they were going to let me direct
the 30 million dollar movies were gone
and that everything was big Marvel
movies and they're never gonna give me
that and yes I would love to do a Hulk
movie that was like a big one at the
time uh you didn't think it was gonna
happen but I didn't think there was any
way it was going to happen